it's hard to believe we are over halfway
through the first season of House of the
Dragon which is a top Contender for my
favorite show of 2022. for those of you
new here this is a spoiler heavy preview
breakdown where nothing is off limits
kinda like a Targaryen marriage if you
want non-spoiler content check out my
episode breakdowns which are filled with
cool details Game of Thrones Easter eggs
and nerdy lore but for now make sure to
like And subscribe we have a juicy
preview to sink our teeth into here we
can see two Valerian soldiers preparing
the casket of Lena Valerian who we know
last episode ordered her Dragon Veigar
to turn her into a crispy skeleton one
of the things I like about this is
seeing how funerals differ from house to
house the targaryens had Emma's body
burned by a dragon in a funeral pile
while here on driftmark there dropped in
the ocean her casket is emblazoned with
the Valerian seahorse emblem and there's
some excellent craftsmanship especially
around the face there's no mention of
her funeral in the book however it is
said rhaenyra came to Dame women's Aid
and comforted him in his grief now in
this preview there's no clearly visible
image of Damon or his daughters
attending this funeral however in the
season 1 trailer we get this image and
it appears this is them over here
notably absent and someone who we
haven't seen yet is Allison and
viserys's fourth child dayron queen
Allison's favorite this could be because
in the book He's a cup Bearer and Squire
to Lord Hightower in Old Town however
considering we'll be seeing Otto
Hightower again it's totally possible he
may have joined with him upon their
return listen to what Corliss says here
what is this brief mortal life
another pursuit of Legacy Corliss hints
at one of the main motivating factors
for many of our characters Legacy and
what better time to bring up Legacy than
at a funeral you'll recall King viserys
asking his hand what his legacy will be
will they sing songs of him or forget
him and my guess is that people will
definitely be talking about Elena's
death for some time dying at the hands
of her own dragon Veigar attending the
funeral from left to right Luke Rainier
Jace Lenor aegon Allison viserys and
Helena aegon and Allison are both
wearing that high tower green we'll see
the casket plummet into the ocean depths
and you can even make out another casket
in the background now this is pretty
cryptic but it looks like a jewelry
perhaps earrings that rhaenice the queen
Who Never Was takes off this might be
after the funeral the now riderless
vegar outside of high tide we can tell
because of this little bit of Castle
appearing over here and matching it with
the wide shot we saw in episode 5. it
looks like vegar Has Come Back to the
Island along with a the corpse of her
former Rider and just to put things into
scale vegar is larger than this whole
freaking clip if you want to be a strong
Queen your subjects must fear you now
the subtitles don't tell us who says
this it sounds like sir Christian but
let me know what you think this is
accompanied with a shot of Allison on
the Royal Targaryen ship here's a shot
of rhaenyra likely somewhere on
driftmark considering she's wearing the
same outfit that we'll see her in at the
funeral this necklace is quite prominent
and I can't help but wonder if she's
made adjustments to her Valerian steel
necklace Damon gave her in episode 1.
perhaps this is some sort of locket and
within it is that necklace a dragon
about to spew out flame I'm going to
guess it's Veigar simply because this
trailer tends to focus on him and
rightly so considering what's about to
go down Vela and Reina watch vegar
before waking up Jace saying that
someone stole the dragon the person
they're referring to is none other than
Eamon who he learned last episode
desperately wants a dragon why not claim
the biggest one alive in one of the
previous trailers we'll see aemond along
the Sands of driftmark claiming this she
beast an event which triggers a truly
disturbing sequence in the book aemond
is caught going after the Beast by a
three-year-old Joffrey of course it
can't play out this way in the show
because Joffrey was just born Eamon
knocks Joffrey down and claims vegar but
upon his return Jason Luke have come to
their brother's defense and a fight
breaks out this culminates in Luke
slashing Eamon to cross the face with a
dagger taking out eamon's right eye in
one of the earlier trailers we see an
adult one-eyed amen the preview here
suggests a slightly altered set of
events it looks like one of Damon's
daughters is hurt you can see some
bruising here so maybe one of the boys
has come to her defense which leads to
eamon's eye being cut out here in the
throne room at high tide we can see a
bloody faced Luke being protected by
Damon rainera and Corliss so this seems
to be the aftermath of this fight we get
a close-up shot of the cat's paw dagger
which will come into play in a bit here
in the Hall of 9 we see Damon taking out
some sort of assassin this is followed
by Lenor defending himself from an
attacker if I were to take a guess Lenor
will die this episode in the book he
slain at the hands of Sir Carl Corey who
he met last episode and there's a ton of
speculation on how and why this occurred
some say Sir Carl was jealous when Lenor
found a new man others that it was Damon
who paid Carl so he could get closer to
renera he is recently single now by the
way this murder however occurs in spice
town near high tide I think this may be
spicetown where we see a cloaked figure
we know Damon sure loves his hooded
cloaks and if you pause it at just the
right moment you can make it what
appears to be white hair otherwise I
would have guessed it may have been one
of lars's henchmen Allison tells the
others that there is a debt to be paid
we can make out a sullen aegon II in the
background Allison is wanting an eye for
an eye since Luke took out eamon's eye
she wants one of Luke's I think this is
Corliss and renice coming down the
stairs to see what all the commotion is
about a brief shot of Jace getting
punched by one of Allison's kids and
take a look at this other body already
on the ground my guess is this is Luke
Damon watches the action unfold as
renera protects her bloody son in the
background she calls the attack the
highest of treasons Jason Luke after all
are second and third in line to the
throne after her in the book Eamon calls
the boys strongs which is the same as
saying they are bastards with no right
of secession and this is an act of
treason Otto here notice that he has
been reinstated as hand of the king I'm
guessing this takes place at driftmark
around the time of the funeral
considering the blue on the fabric in
the back that no good Laura sets his
eyes on Allison I'm sure he'll have
something planned that she won't like at
all vegar flies through the sky I wonder
if this is eamon's First Flight with her
Allison grabs the cat's paw Dagger from
the king's belt in the book The King
denies her request for an eye for an eye
and Rainier's family goes back to
Dragonstone while Allison's to King's
Landing there's no big attempted murder
as seen here in the preview where
Allison lunges at rhaenyra here's an
interesting shot of Otto and who appears
to be aegon he might be pissed at his
grandson for venturing out so late
another shot of Damon attacking that
Intruder a close-up shot of Otto with
the hand of the Kingpin and rhaenyra
with a bloody hand this looks really
fresh and gushing so it's probably from
the aftermath of Allison's attack there
is also a hand closely behind her so I'm
guessing this is corlisses as we've seen
him behind her in this shot the pace of
this show has just been insane which is
making me question just where season one
will end we do know the king will die
this season I wonder if in the finale
we'll see the beginning of the dance of
dragons essentially making the first 10
episodes a precursor to one of the
bloodiest events in westerosi history so
to wrap things up it looks like we're
gonna see Lena's funeral Eamonn claiming
vegar potentially the death of Lenor and
eamon's eye being plucked out so just a
typical totally non-violent episode
check out my episode 6 breakdown if you
haven't taking a look at it and make
sure to like And subscribe and leave a
comment on what you think will happen
next for more bad takes you can follow
me on Twitter and Instagram at
thingsstory YT until next time remember
[Music]